Stars, galaxy, in astral seas above, on cosmic paths we'll trace, man's where wings, is such a wonder thing, behind the deuce of roms, see come take your place, we're leaving soon for-
You'll see as to just what I need, so what is my size location?
Oh good at all, 2023, was the year that we departed, again, another idea, get a rest, but not now, alright, how long?
So, more than a century.
Have any idea how long, any at all?
A whole millennium, then we might say that, and why not?
Why not?
Eh, he's a nice computer, only she always wants to be the center of attention.
To work, now.
I'm at this!
And as close as that!
My goodness!
Sisters, there's nothing like 'em.
They need their beauty sleep, I guess.
Better let 'em sleep.
I'll just have a bite to eat.
Mm-hmm.
What is on the menu today?
You need to feel like a little snack.
Now, various meats, vegetables, fish, very tasty fish, most forgotten.
No, no, it was nothing like a good meal when you're hungry.
The best elements of the orbital graph, compensation for the, let's see, the star cluster.
A couple of sleepyheads finally awake, eh?
I don't know how, but we're in orbit.
Right, we're approaching.
We did it.
We're right on destination, and let's see, according to my calculations,
I would say that we have traveled a distance of about 27,800 light years, more or less.
What I'm wondering is how long it's been in real time.
Ah, yes, as a famous author said, that is the question.
Anyway, our chrono-calculator is blocked on the year of our departure.
Now, to calculate the length of any voyage,
I divide the distance by the relatively distortion of space-time
reduced to a factor I can calculate without knowing the elapsed voyage time.
Simple.
But I thought you were the navigator.
Why don't you check the calculations?
As for you, give the ship a mechanical checkup.
- I'm pretty sure it needs it.
- It's hard to believe it's been so long.
It feels like I went to sleep last night.
- I admit I feel the same.
- But my young friends, imagine the glory
that awaits the three of us.
That should wake you up.
We three are the first to discover the whole cosmos
from the first time in history for all mankind.
And man's foot is going to tread on new planets
yet undreamed of this foot.
And try to imagine the species of living creatures
we will discover truly an extraordinary adventure.
It might take any form at all, possibly.
Each form it will be, anything they want, tiny or gigantic, peaceful or hostile.
The radar screen.
Speaking. By yourself. Fly. Your identification.
Go and plug in a radio. This is Spaceship Lerio, based on Earth.
Mission Galactic Exploration. This is Spaceship Lerio, based on Earth.
Our mission is intergalactic exploration. He's deaf.
Intelligent life elsewhere. They don't look all that intelligent, I'll admit.
Look at those ships. That's technology.
Human, look at them.
We are warmly welcome, the courageous space pioneers.
Our guard of honor will accompany you to the landing area.
You ever have imagined a city like that?
Truly spectacular sight.
The fantastic setup they got here.
Follow my instructions for landing procedure.
President of the Commission of Omega,
I welcome you to our planet, valiant pioneers of space.
President? Federation?
President, forgive my appearing a little bit deaf.
It's just that I am, how shall I say, surprised,
Because I never expected to find beings, well, perhaps with a civilization, but how shall I say, rather distinctive, like these gentlemen, I apologize.
But I'm countering the far end of the galaxy, a collection of creatures like you, that's surprising.
But we are from Earth, didn't you know?
Things?
Yes, originally. We've been here for centuries.
But we would like to hear your story. In 2023, you left the Earth to sleep.
Yeah, the best sleep I ever had.
Or more precisely, into a state of suspended animation.
Technology made great leaps forward.
Space ships were made bigger and bigger and grew to be quite numerous.
About two centuries later, just after the Great Intercontinental War,
the link with our galaxy no longer was a problem.
Today, if you wish to return home, your trip would require no more than six to eight days.
Six to eight days? Well, it took us.
Yes, you required about a thousand years. I think you'll agree it's astonishing.
Astonishing, as you say. But, um, that is...
Your onboard radio wasn't equipped to send out signals.
anywhere near what was required to stay in contact in history books describing your departure,
you were considered lost, and that was the end of your story.
You were off in space, never to return, perished in your ship, lost forever.
But we weren't lost at all.
From time to time, a radar echo would appear, a moving object in the distance,
but so weak since your craft was so little.
In space these days, there are all kinds of UFOs, unidentified flying objects.
Naturally, they weren't sure.
Yes, that sounds logical.
We have notified authorities on Earth and other planets of the Confederation about your exploit.
You are honored as heroes in all the inhabited worlds.
But I am sure you're tired after your journey.
I suggest you rest now.
Tomorrow the Council will look forward to meeting you, three heroes.
And this unique experience for mankind is witnessed by your distinguished presence.
For the first time, it is vouchsafed to man to experience the continuity of a thousand years of progress.
And I am proud and delighted to have been back.
Where was I? What was I saying?
And to see how man has evolved in harmony and peace.
I say man, of course, I include all of you, naturally.
This dignified assembly demonstrates to us to what heights man may strive.
Progress that is based on intelligence, sincere, harmonious cooperation.
Well, we mustn't expect too much. There's a way to go.
There are exceptions to the rule.
I've seen that old guy. Where was it?
Where was it?
The old guy's off again.
Where was I?
Who is he reminds me of? Who is he?
I have brought with me testimony to the greatness of mankind on Earth.
You will find in these boxes a condensation of our science, as well as culture and advanced technology,
and I may say, with absolute certainty, all the secrets of mankind's superiority are contained here.
It is a great treasure to be guarded jealously.
It's up to you now, Mr. Head.
Naturally, there is no machine here able to read these secrets, I quite understand.
And so we shall look now to building a transcoder. When it is ready, I shall be delighted to address you again. I thank you for your welcome.
You're great, Professor. You did a great job.
I'll look after these.
Cassettes.
Now we have only...
Where are the cassettes?
Where did they go?
Where are they?
Cassettes.
Chief is going to be a happy man.
But you'd like to know. We've got the cassettes right here.
That one, what does it do?
One, as you put it, is an intellectual, and I've never been referred to as it.
Oh, I do beg your pardon. I should have known.
As you can see, he has a nice disposition, always even-tempered.
We call that psychological osmosis, in case you're interested.
Look here, my lad. Why don't you come with me to Earth?
They'd like a peek at your circuits. I know they'd be interested.
I should go and put on a show for these backward savages.
I fail to see the point in that. It's like throwing swine to pearls.
That is enough of that. Be quiet.
Forty generations have lived and died since I left the Earth a thousand years ago.
It's hard to understand such time.
Naturally, it is.
It's just that when you departed Earth, your ship had a number of unresolved difficulties.
It was early days.
Yes, yes, first of all, you never went in a straight line toward the objective.
Mathematicians had to calculate and define orbits to get you there.
You clocked with great precision the exact place of all the large bodies in your immediate region and their gravitation.
We're back in prehistory.
Now our ships are equipped with a field of force that cancels out gravitation.
It was also in our power. We needed propulsion, and our ion engine was considered a breakthrough, the best theoretical engine.
In the year 2093, 160 years after your departure, there was a terrible intercontinental war, which ravaged the Earth, but it stimulated progress in space exploration.
The speed of light was soon to be attained. But today, we are able to go into hyperspace, which stays linear, but antimatter is just around the corner.
It opens a whole new future.
Consider an individual at any instant
can be anywhere in the universe.
Interesting. It really is most intriguing.
Only answer one question.
Anti-matter supposes anti-time,
and when particles and anti-particles
collide with each other,
they risk losing their identity in the physical world,
causing a disappearance of the universe, time, space,
and any travelers who happen to be on their way
someplace far works.
Well, well, not bad thinking for a caveman.
No one asked you.
A shrewd observation,
But this problem is very nearly solved now.
What is not so easy to solve is how to materialize a traveler at a certain location in the galaxy.
And how to make such individuals return home.
For if we do succeed in achieving the first phase of the journey,
it isn't 40 generations which will be needed in order to return,
but 40,000 generations, a million years, and with no means of going into an arrested state.
Just think of that.
Here you can observe the movement of all spacecraft in flight anywhere in the galaxy.
Their trajectories are traced on the screen.
And did nothing ever elude your detection?
No.
Yes, one thing did happen not long ago.
Oh, yes, and what was that?
Here are your guides.
If you will please follow them, you will learn more about Planet Omega.
Receiving a shipment of minerals from outlying colonies.
I don't know how to do it.
Well, the colonies are too far away to take you there.
These are Carbocraft.
We're going to pay a visit to our suburbs, that is, if you would like to see them.
Would I like to see them?
Link to screen display.
What is that ahead there?
What's that?
That... What is it?
Robots extracting minerals.
These asteroids are the remnants of a disintegrated planet.
That's why the region is rich in minerals, as you can see.
There are 54 robots and two men.
Gerald.
How are you doing?
Technician Poole.
We're doing all right, Lieutenant.
It ain't a sight. It really is.
And then what is that enormous crap?
Explain it to our friend. You're supposed to be the scientist.
It's one of our tankers.
They guarantee supplies of hydrogen, which we need in great quantities.
In outer space, there is an unlimited supply.
Oh, yes.
Combined with dust particles from earlier stellar explosions,
it gravitates towards a center eventually to form new stars.
Of course, the process takes millions of centuries.
Oh, yeah, of course, of course.
These tankers collect hydrogen, concentrate it, and store it until it is needed.
Oh, yeah.
It seems a logical procedure, but, and yet, it's dangerous.
Yes, it's not as simple as all that.
We've had a certain number of hydrogen accidents.
If a tanker makes an abrupt encounter with the dense, gaseous clouds, there is an explosion.
Now the techniques are perfected.
Ah! We're coming to a larger mineral gathering station.
Ah, you know, on Earth, I mean, at least back in my time,
we had run out of minerals, so we started melting down junk.
The crazy years, the end of the 20th century, used it all up.
Well, what did we do when every city was choked with cars?
What else? They made more cars.
And then for a while, they raided old car dumps, anything to get minerals.
Any kind of old metal was taken and melted down, and then that ran out.
Don't worry, my friend. Here is the solution for the future.
That's what I call a cat's pajamas.
The machines extract minerals, and they are instantly processed and put into a container ship.
This is Lieutenant Piero. Is everything under control?
Hello, Lieutenant. Chief Engineer Robert here. Everything's normal, except...
What is it, Chief Engineer?
Well, the last train loaded with minerals left four hours ago.
For the last two hours, we have been expecting confirmation of arrival. A bit strange, you agree?
It should have arrived by now. It's never happened before.
Their radio may have gone out.
That's what we suppose, Lieutenant. Radios all at once.
We'll contact our station. Let us know of any new developments.
Yes, Lieutenant. Thanks.
Four hours. If you go into hyperspace, we could miss them.
If you go on in normal space, it'll take us at least seven hours to catch them.
That is, if you're right on guessing the direction they took.
Otherwise, with every second that goes by,
their chances of disappearing into a corner of the galaxy increases exponentially.
I think I can guess the direction they've taken.
Yes, so can I. And it's the same direction.
If we calculate our hyperspace configuration to within a fraction of a second,
And we just might...
Let's try it, Piero.
And you, how about a brief introduction to hyperspace?
Think that'll be all right?
Oh, don't ask me twice!
With an experience like that, do you think I wouldn't miss a thing like that?
You go ahead, I'm not scared.
Ready? Let's go.
Antigravitation shield.
The train.
Using magnetic destroyers.
It's hard to get close to the magnetic protection field wasn't operating.
See if there's any damage.
I'll contact Omega.
Central computer, okay.
Propulsion, okay.
Gravitation, okay.
Airtight seals, okay.
Guidance system, okay. Radar screen, not okay. There is a slight leak in the hermetic ceiling.
This is Omega Control. Come in, Lieutenant Piero.
This is Lieutenant Piero. We've managed to find that mineral train.
Diverted from mineral base HX-41, we've been hit by a mine and able to give chase.
Do we open fire?
This is the commander. Do not fire, Piero. Train must be recovered. It's vital.
I'll send a squadron to intercept. Can you make it back?
We'll see, commander. Pressure in the cabin?
Pressure at maximum. It will hold for a while, not long.
Circular periscoping position.
Piero, look!
Too bad Metro isn't here. He could go out there and repair it.
I guess I'll have to try.
Now you stay at the control. Remain in radio contact.
Terrific sight. I think I can repair the damage.
Loud and clear, Piero. Only hurry, there isn't much time.
I've almost finished the repair job.
Broken metal shielding doesn't want to come off.
Oh, Piero, please, it's okay. It will hold like that.
He's lost in space.
Oh my goodness, what can we do?
The only thing you can do is let me concentrate.
Piero, where are you?
Piero, you must hear me.
Piero, you hear me?
Piero, speak to me.
Piero, you're talking to me, Piero.
It's the only way I can find you.
Keep it tight, speak to me.
Go on, don't stop talking.
See the ship, I can see you.
Wait a minute, Piero, I'll turn the ship
so you can enter by the rear deck.
That old crate never looks so cut.
You'll be all right, Piero, it's over now.
You've made up your mind.
Oh, yes, Madam President. I'm going to return to Earth. Sorry, my companions want to stay here, but I'll admit things go a bit too quickly for me here.
But on Earth, things have changed, too.
No doubt, no doubt. But Earth is my home. I want to see it. There are some things that certainly couldn't have changed.
No word on the Space Jack train. Have to take action.
I'd be glad to, but action against whom?
One guess.
Suspicion of guilt is not enough, and you know it.
Very well. I am convening a summit meeting. We'll see.
Is this train so important?
Yes, it is, but it's top secret, in the hands of a troublemaker.
Well, there are some curious goings on there.
Right. Too many. I wonder if it's who I think it is.
One day we'll come to visit you.
On Earth!
There's a promise.
Oh, my goodness.
We're glad you came.
So, Wander, come take your place.